[Music]
[Music]
so books I have gifted the most other
people there are many the first that
comes to mind is any collection of the
letters from a stoic or more commonly
known in academic circles as the moral
letters to Luke Ilya spiced Seneca so I
actually gave away these for free
because they're in the public domain
with illustrations and so on as the Tao
of Seneca because I've given away
hundreds and thousands of copies it
really teaches you what I consider
perhaps the ultimate operating system
for thriving in high stress environments
at least one of them then I would say
also because I read nothing but
nonfiction for more than a decade I
really like to gift people I know
Taipei driven people fiction because I
think many of the principles and truths
contained in stories are better absorbed
through fiction Zorba the Greek
specifically stands out which chronicles
the adventures of this very brainy very
analytical person which I see is more
myself who makes all manner of mistakes
in life because of that and then this
free willing crazy person Zorba the
Greek so I highly highly recommend that
book and then also there's a book called
stranger in a strange land by Robert
Heinlein which is incredible and if
you've ever wondered where the word grok
oh i grok that i don't rock that where
that came from it's commonly used in
tech circles came from that book and
it's about a Martian developing as a
human being on earth it's a spectacular
spectacular book and I would say last
but certainly not least would be surely
I think it is surely you're joking mr.
Fineman along those lines you'll find it
and it is a book written by richard
fineman incredible physicist involved
with manhattan project but also a
polymath and had taught himself how to
play the bongos how to crack safes how
to paint which he learned doing in strip
clubs fascinating hilarious guy expert
at problem-solving and also a very very
very famous teacher he could take
complex
physics concepts and break them down to
the point where all he needed was say an
apple and a pen and he could explain
something that would normally take years
of prereqs so those are a few of the
books that I have gifted the most other
people hey guys if you're enjoying the
tips and tactics and how-to on this
channel or in the podcast the Tim
Ferriss show I made this for you try the
mentors short advice from the best in
the world this is the book that I wanted
to read so I went out and I put it
together created a dream list a hundred
and thirty of the best at what they do
people who are icons legends and ask
them all the same questions these are
people in some cases I wanted to reach
out to my whole life ranges from many
many billionaires cofounders of every
company imaginable elite athletes
ranging from surfing to tennis to
powerlifting everything else country
stars actors directors and you can spot
the pattern so some of my friends have
said this is the easiest to read most
useful book that I've put together yet
so check it out tribal mentors calm you
can find sample chapters the whole list
of mentors everything tribal mentors
calm